and it's the next day and we have a a
less full day yesterday was crazy the
first day was crazy uh we're waking up
we are awake we are going
to uh try a coffee place um there's one
coffee place that opens there's one
place that has great coffee and a great
canoli but no indoor seating so I think
we try a canoli getting get one coffee
to share just to taste it then we're
going to go to a actual coffee shop uh
and sit down and I brought some
computers and we're going to do some
health research and journeying for the
next 11 years of us being together and
then what are we doing next we're going
to go do some we're going to do fun
stuff we're going to do lunch we're
going to do a massage we're going to do
some hiking and you're coming with us
let's
[Music]
go
so we arrived at the the popup a popup
no container coffee and um supposed to
be the best uh the best coffee best
coffee in the best canoli here we go
yeah try the coffee best latte in Colin
we're in Collinwood which is just
outside Blue
Mountain this is just uh she said sweet
this is a non-sweet this is just a
regular
L yeah good yeah it's pretty good do you
want to
try this one then
okay next we got the famous
canoli
original and what's the other one
Pistachio Pistachio original
pistachio let's go with the original
first good it's pretty good
I half Italian so Italian food is hard
to get mhm it's pretty good it's a
little sweet for
um for a
original but it's pretty good for a food
truck and cing
wood it's pretty
good good
[Music]
job all right next stop Evan next stop
is Heavenly Cafe okay while we coming
here there are two options uh for coffee
places apart from like Tim Hortons and
Starbucks whatever one uh they both had
uh decent reviews one was a 4.6 review
but they were they got a lot of good
feedback for their low prices but uh the
complaints were it was really bad
coffee so then this place is a
4.4 and they got the opposite uh
negative reviews for their high prices
but good coffee so like okay let's send
Nina some good coffee so we're going to
go inside Heavenly Cafe uh apparently
has a French vibe to it we got our
laptops and we're going to do some
health research and planning and uh
seeing how we can take care of ourselves
for the next 11 years let's
[Music]
go
hello Evan hello how was the ca Cafe I
liked it it's different Vibes yeah I
liked it yeah it's good better than the
other place probably did some good
health research going to do some testing
comprehensive hormone
panel testosterone cholesterol all sorts
of testing see how we're doing set of
baselines and learn how we can uh
improve ourselves uh the the Canadian
doctors unfortunately only test you if
there's a reason to test you they don't
do baselines on a lot of lipids and
everything else so we're going to take
matters into our own hands pay for our
own testing and see where we're at but
before we go yeah where are we going to
go there's a dog going for a walk we
going for a walk but there's a dog store
I want to check it out oh yeah no forget
the Walk we're going to a dog store no
we're going to walk after too but check
out the dog store yeah we're going to go
forget the walk first that's not a good
idea Dog store first then walk and then
and then what go see the dogs and then
go see our dogs that's what we're
[Music]
doing okay we pick up two stuff for the
dogs a one is the homemade treat that
has all sorts of ingredients and then
they they made this in the store yeah so
they're going to love this stuff and
then what else you bought this this one
it's more to clean their teeth the
plaque on their teeth clean their teeth
yeah they're going to love it yeah
they're going to love
it everyone to walk around so we stumble
into sport check and what did you decide
to get Evan how you feeling oh you got
some yetis you want to show them yeah we
got a lot of the yetis well we we got
some Yeti
tumblers because the dishwash is safe so
that we can just leave in the dishwasher
we don't have to handh it buy three
black ones and then just get in the
white and the paint nah Nina's getting
this white in the pink I actually I like
pink Evan yeah so what did you end up
buying other stuff the best touchcreen
gloves I've ever seen in my life really
yeah get your phone get my phone let me
see let me it didn't capture in camera
does it mean that if it's not on camera
then it didn't count yeah okay hold on
let's put this up here let me let me get
my
phone okay well it's on lock screen
ready oh my hold on let's not show you
my password but look at how I unlocked
it oh my goodness oh my goodness look at
that look at that red actually okay look
at us hold on let's do a
selfie 1 2 3 bam took a picture can't
even even see too bright bam you know
hello they're not the warmest clothes
but but it's great this is under
arour I don't remember what it's called
Uh something Under Armour is awesome
let's
go usually they say woman like to shop I
think Evan today especially I don't like
the shop you just oh let's go to sporta
oh let's go to Whole Depot oh let's go
to there
I was like okay I'll just follow you
well we're
uh want an adventure you know this is
great we're done shopping are we yeah I
think so oh what else is there to walk
to that's an organic eery is that where
we're going I think so no yeah it is so
we're here okay great no we went to Nina
bought some uh early Christmas presents
for the family yeah so you can't blame
me on this one it was it was uh nah
buying some Christmas presents yeah
Nina's already thinking ahead she's uh
the glue for the family another reason
why we love
[Music]
her I've been pick up some food they
didn't have Ki and nothing really
appealing to me so I didn't get anything
anything but I haven't got a green
smoothie Taco bow yeah and green
smoothie I haven't had it
yet good oh wow it's it's their homemade
almond milk in here
try
fresh good so now we're going to go back
to the car finally yeah yeah our 15
minute walk turned into a 2our adventure
Shing 2our shopping
Street
[Music]
we went back chill a bit EV watched
League of Legend I'm stretching my Cals
right now why well on a on a on a
downhill slope we did a lot of walking
yesterday and a my Cals are tight so I'm
on the hill now to stretch them what are
we doing right now we're going for a
walk yep and then uh with the dogs with
the dogs and then we're going to a
volcanic rock rock spa room yeah and
then we're doing a massage and then
we're going to go for dinner and then
maybe we're going to do our
nighttime Gondola Gondola thing we'll
see okay let's
[Music]
go
what's next Evan um can you even see I
can't see what's next we're going to our
spa treatment we're going to go this
place is famous for having uh volcanic
Rock Room which has all sorts of healing
properties that I have forgotten about
but we're going to we're going to lie on
some volcanic rock for half an hour and
then do a deep tissue massage which one
did we get yeah deep tissue massage to
loosen up that
neck uh and then dinner let's
go well Evan is is in his row I'm in the
same rope we're in the same size rope
yeah the Rope my row is basically down
to my shin shins yeah mine to the knees
yeah this is volcanic rock yeah we're
going to lie down here oh instructions
are coming yeah we're going to die down
here relax and
[Music]
enjoy how you feeling Evan that was good
did you nap uh I almost passed out and
then you moved oh I don't know what you
were doing oh I was lying to my to I was
lying on my stomach oh you made a bunch
of noise that's fine Sor and and then I
then I just relaxed but I was almost out
oh okay sorry now they've
got supposed to do here this keeps
coming up
then cold lavender towels oh wow this is
cold okay try
it oh my gosh this is
cold
[Music]
okay it's freezing cold you should try
it yeah okay I'll try
it how was your massage Evan wa did you
not film any of that nothing any of it
oh perfect okay well very relaxing yeah
very relaxing you had a you had a very
tight calves very tight Cal and then
when she started pushing on it I almost
fell asleep Yeah Yeah from all the
hiking and bouncing and
all day yeah yeah okay
[Music]
good all right next up this is our
dinner place it is one of uh radio one
of the highest uh Vietnamese restaurant
in the town and I went up no it is the
highest Vietnamese restaurant oh so
highest one of the highest restaurants
in Collingwood but definitely the best
me Collingwood is a small town okay
exactly the I read I read the review
some uh even Asian and Vietnamese rated
that's has a good food so we got to
[Music]
go okay here she goes this is the shrim
shm
roll fly get
away mhm
Okay evan mhm how was your meal how was
your P pretty good yeah yeah you like it
yeah I mean I'm not I'm not the biggest
Vietnamese food I fish shado but you're
you're more the food snob Asian food
snob mhm yours was M the soup is hot
soup is hot wow that's so that's good
okay the soup you don't want that soup
come not hot is it not usually hot a lot
of no a lot of time the restaurant the
soup is not hot but this one the soup is
hot which is good okay the flavor I
found it a little bit lighter on my end
maybe I'm just I like something more
stronger flavor but yeah yeah pretty
good okay next up we're going to go home
pick up the dos and go for a walk in the
village and then go back to
[Music]
relax good morning Evan Carmichael today
is the last day we're going home it's
very excited it's a lot of excitement
are you excited that it's the last day
that we're going home or excited that we
had a good time we had a good time yeah
and then we had the doggies joining us
number anniversary yeah you're good boy
so if you want to see how this all began
check your video right there next to me
I think you'll love it continue to
believe and we'll see you there